[Music]
there is a sickness inside us rising
like the bile that leaves that bitter
taste to the back of our throats it's
there on every one of you seated around
the table only when we know what ails us
can we hope to find the cure
what do you make of that clear these
fosters mind all thoughts exactly
I'd like you to go to Switzerland and
bring mr. pinburrough
back to us what we offer here the
process of purification away from
precious the modern world your plans to
take mr. Pembroke back with you is that
a problem
he's a patient not a prisoner yes dick
you know actually I was just leaving who
never leaves welcome back mr. Locher
signs are concussion to get the immune
system I would like to recommend a
treatment
think of it as a cleansing of the mind
as much as the body some patients
experience issues addressed assured it's
just the toxins leaving the system
I see that was 200 years ago this is
happening now
said no no police what happened civil I
saw the buys listen to yourself you're
not a well man
you trying to make me think I see it to
be it's all part of the cure there is no
jaw accept the diagnosis
it's wonderful here I read a lot